on February the 24 2022 was the first
wave of Russian troops crossed the
border as Russian missiles Struck it
fast became clear that Vladimir Putin's
insistence that he would not invade
Ukraine had been a lie
it was a multi-pronged attack Russian
forces crossed from Belarus and advanced
towards cave there was a similar push in
the Northeast
and in the East towards Ukraine's Second
City kharkiv at the same time mainly
pro-russia separatist forces attacked
towns in ukrainian-controlled areas of
Donetsk and mugansk
Ukrainian president not yet in his
trademark military fatigues called for
help
I had a conversation with U.S President
Joe Biden the U.S is starting to gather
International support
poor planning and brave Ukrainian
defense quickly scaffolded Putin's
immediate plans to take give
Russian army columns were soon bogged
down and smashed
the enemy poorly calculated their
Communications in logistic needs and
their supply warehouses were across the
border this meant that after two days
they were stopped without fuel
ammunition and food and they lost the
effective management of their troops
on the 1st of April Ukraine announced it
had recaptured the entire region around
Kiev
dead civilians some with their hands
bound behind their backs were discovered
seemingly where they had been shot
Russia was accused of war crimes
the Russian army which Ukrainian
intelligence says had planned on taking
control of Kiev in three days had
suffered a historic and humiliating
defeat
in May after months of intense fighting
in the port city of mariopol the last
Romanian Ukrainian Fighters surrendered
at the azov style steel plant
but Ukraine by now is receiving what
would become tens of billions of dollars
worth of military aid
Autumn counter-offensive liberated tens
of thousands of square kilometers
including the city of kirison
preparations for the counter-offensive
started in April by June when we had
received Western weapons we were better
able to hit their supply lines command
centers and weapons and fuel Depots we
could also attack the reserve troops as
they approached the front line
since December Ukrainian gains have
slowed to a virtual standstill Russia
has made small advances in eastern
donbass using what Ukrainian forces say
is wave after wave of infantry soldiers
and mercenaries from the Wagner group
some of the heaviest fighting continues
around the town of bakmut where many of
the estimated 5 000 civilians Who Remain
there refuse to be evacuated
officials here in Kiev and their Western
allies are convinced that Russia is
about to launch what they describe as a
spring offensive more sophisticated
Weaponry such as tanks is on its way
from NATO countries but with no end in
sight to the fighting many are asking
just how long Ukraine's allies can fund
this war despite their leaders saying it
is a fight for democracy they cannot
lose Charles Stratford Al Jazeera heave